l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion de
la proposition de loi relative aux
bibliothèques et au développement de la
lecture publique présenté par madame
sylvie robert et plusieurs de ses
collègues demande du groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains
la procédure accélérée a été engagée sur
ce texte
dans la discussion générale la parole et
à madame sylvie robert auteur de la
proposition de loi et rapporteur de la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la communication pour 20minutes
chers collègues je vous remercie
bien madame la présidente madame la
ministre
ce président de la commission mes chers
collègues fallait-il une loi sur les
bibliothèques
cette question peut paraître provocante
puisque proposant à vos suffrages ma
proposition de loi relative aux
bibliothèques et au développement de la
lecture publique
la réponse semble aller de soi en
réalité elle témoigne d'un long
cheminement qui a émaillé la réflexion
autour de l'opportunité d'une loi sur
les bibliothèques et que de débats au
sein des professionnels alors précisé
mais ne pas brider encadré mais ne pas
enfermer l'équilibré trouvé n'a pas été
aussi évident et harkis d'intenses
réflexions avec le ministère de la
culture que je veux très sincèrement
remerciés et notamment la direction du
livre et de la lecture mais aussi les
professionnels mais aussi les
collectivités territoriales et les élus
cette proposition loi est l'expression
d'un compromis unanime je pense pouvoir
dire en faveur de la reconnaissance et
de l'importance des bibliothèques et des
bibliothécaires
elle est aussi l'expression de mon
attachement profond aux bibliothèques et
une reconnaissance pour les personnels
qui les font vivre et pour les millions
de nos concitoyens qui chaque jour en
pousse les portes
peu importe la raison car lire parcourir
les rayons bien sûr mais aussi écouter
un auteur visiter une exposition
participer à un débat à un atelier pour
refaire son cv ou pour réviser le bac un
tournoi de jeux vidéo aller sur internet
et tant d'autres activités qu'il
faudrait une dg entière est peut-être
plus que 20 minutes pour être exhaustive
en somme la bibliothèque est une
expérience culturelle ludique mais aussi
sociale et la bibliothèque et ce lieu
unique exceptionnel qui ouvre à tous est
possible
ce qu'alberto écho dans son opuscule des
bibliothèques à appelle la bibliothèque
univers je cite si la bibliothèque et
comme le veut borgès un modèle de
l'univers essayons de le transformer en
un univers à la mesure de l'homme une
bibliothèque où l'on ait envie d'aller
qui progressivement se transformerait en
une grande machine pour le temps libre
un lieu de livres bien sûr mais
également
un lieu de vie saint-augustin écrivait
je crains l'homme d'un seul livre dans
notre époque marquée par la violence du
débat politique par le dogmatisme par
l'enfermement dans des certitudes
souvent facile les bibliothèques
s'imposent comme des lieux
indispensables de respiration citoyenne
et civique des lieux d'émancipation où
chacune et chacun peut se forger un
esprit critique en sommes aujourd'hui et
plus que jamais un lieu de raison et de
liberté et je ne crois pas qu'il y a eu
de hasard lorsque la lors de la
construction de notre hémicycle en 1837
que c'est une bibliothèque cap dole
faîtière a choisi de faire édifier à
quelques pas de la salle de séance
nous avons encore aujourd'hui le
privilège de siéger à quelques mètres
d'une des plus belles bibliothèques de
france qui nous offre souvent dans un
cadre privilégié
l'occasion surtout de prendre un peu de
recul sur notre action politique est un
peu de distance face à la vitesse de
notre actualitté contemporaine plus
concrètement avec ma proposition de loi
j'ai souhaité porter deux objectifs
ancré profondément les bibliothèques
dans notre droit d'une part et conforter
leur lien avec les collectivités
territoriales dans le plein respect de
leur liberté de gestion et renforcer les
politiques publiques en matière de
lecture publique d'autre part j'ai
souhaité tout d'abord ancrée
profondément dans notre droit les
bibliothèques les dispositions qui les
concerne ne représente aujourd'hui que
cinq articles dans le code du patrimoine
sans même une définition de leurs
missions soit 12 fois moins que pour les
archives en réalité mes chers collègues
il n'a jamais eu dans notre pays de loi
sur les bibliothèques
telle est la finalité de ma proposition
loi qui constitue pour ces
établissements
une consécration législative et pour moi
l'aboutissement de plusieurs années de
travail de multiples rencontres
ainsi bien sûr de réflexion nourrie par
mon expérience d'élu à la culture à
rennes et en bretagne ainsi que de mes
travaux parlementaires
mon rapport parlementaire de 2015 sur
l'adaptation l'extension des horaires
d'ouverture des bibliothèques avait
permis la mise en place d'un dispositif
de soutien financier de l'état à
destination des collectivités
territoriales parallèlement le sujet
s'impose dans le débat
bli conforté par la mission orsenna
corbin en 2018 et par le lancement par
le ministère de la culture d'un plan
bibliothèque visant à ouvrir plus et
mieux
ce plan s'accompagnera d'une
augmentation de la dgd de 8 millions
d'euros soit un investissement total de
88 millions d'euros
et puis j'ai présenté en juillet dernier
à la commission de la culture avec ma
collègue colette mélot un rapport
d'information consacrée à l'évaluation
de cette politique publique en faveur de
l'extension des horaires d'ouverture
donc c'était un rapport très intéressant
en tout cas à mener car de cette
réflexion au long cours est née la
certitude qu'il fallait enfin donner un
cadre un statut des missions donc un
cadre assez bibliothèque municipale
intercommunale et départementales qui
font vivre nos territoires
il était impératif de fixer plusieurs
grands principes principe qui d'ailleurs
ont pu être mis en cause y compris ces
dernières semaines alors même qu'ils
sont au fondement des bibliothèques le
pluralisme des courants d'idées et
d'opinions l'égalité la liberté la
gratuité d'accès la neutralité du
service public
dans la très grande majorité des cas ils
sont déjà pratiquée au quotidien
si bien que les énoncés les renforce et
les conforte il sécurise aussi
juridiquement et peuvent prévenir des
dérives que nous avons vu à l'oeuvre
récemment mais avec cette proposition de
loi j'ai également voulu souligner le
lien entre les collectivités
territoriales et leurs bibliothèques
je n'ai pas voulu imposer des
contraintes supplémentaires ni des
dépenses nouvelles
nous savons trop comme élus locaux qui
vaut mieux laisser l'initiative au plus
proche du terrain et qu'il est
préférable que la loi fixe les grands
principes les objectifs tout en laissant
la latitude aux collectivités pour y
tendre mais je souhaite que les élus
s'emparent pleinement du sujet et
établissent dans leur cité une véritable
politique culturelle et éducative qui
fasse rayonner les bibliothèques sur
leur territoire car comme élu nous avons
tous des témoignages convergents et la
semaine dernière encore en commission de
la capacité remarquable des
bibliothécaires à réinventer leur métier
leur passion dans les territoires les
témoignages de mes collègues étaient
vraiment très touchant car on le sait
les bibliothécaires sont dans une
évolution permanente
elles font preuve
souvent elles jeudi d'une capacité à
s'adapter à créer parfois d'ailleurs
avec peu de moyens mais qui doit être
salué c'est aussi grâce à eux à elle que
les bibliothèques et je veux associer à
cette idée erik orsenna et noël corbin
sont des endroits vivants qui ont su
accompagner l'évolution des usages avec
le numérique mais aussi inventer créer
et innover
alors au delà des symboles les
bibliothécaires attendait depuis
longtemps l'inscription dans la loi des
missions des établissements et je veux
profiter de cette tribune pour leur
témoigner ma reconnaissance à la fois
amicales mais aussi admiratif ou leur
travail au quotidien
car leur sens du service public
s'accordent parfaitement avec leur
mission de service public et
bibliothèques on se constitue
effectivement le seul service public où
vous pouvez venir en toute liberté
rester toute une journée si vous le
voulez sans que personne ne vienne vous
sollicité pour autre chose peut-être
d'un conseil
ce sont des lieux de sociabilité des
lieux de croisement de toutes les
populations des lieux d'accueil de
bienveillance et je dirais d'hospitalité
si j'ai volontairement recherché dans
cette proposition de loi le consensus le
plus large
il n'en reste pas moins que des sujets
essentiels attendent encore d'être
traités il a également un chaînage
vertus entre les collectivités
territoriales et les bibliothèques à
consolider cette première lecture ici au
sénat constitue pour moi un moment très
important et je m'adresse à madame la
ministre car je sais pouvoir compter sur
votre engagement et votre force de
conviction vous l'avait déjà démontré en
m'accordant et je vous en remercie
sincèrement la procédure accélérée
mais c'est aussi une première étape qui
en appelle au moins deux autres avant la
fin de l'année tout d'abord nous aurons
à reparler très prochainement des
biotech départementale est assurément de
la situation en outre-mer probablement
dans le cadre de l'examen de la future
loi cadre des 3ds je ne sais plus et qui
arrive en juillet au sénat
ensuite il nous faudra mes chers
collègues dans le cadre du prochain
projet de loi de finances nous assurer
tous ensemble de la pérennisation des
moyens des bibliothèques qui ont
bénéficié ces dernières années de
crédits supplémentaires au sein de la
dgd car cette réforme ne doit pas rester
sans lendemain
il faut que ces crédits deviennent
pérennes temps les résultats enregistrés
nous l'avons
dans la mission d'information dans le
rapport avec colette mélot ont été
spectaculaires en termes d'adaptation et
d'ouverture au public
voilà madame la présidente madame la
ministre je ne vais pas utiliser mes
vingt minutes car ça n'est pas
nécessaire car mes chers collègues
l'esprit qui m'anime et qui font la
proposition de loi que j'ai l'honneur et
le plaisir de vous présenter aujourd'hui
est celui là je suis sensible aussi à la
concomitance de la présentation de la ma
proposition loin avec celle de ma
collègue laure darcos
hier sur l'économie du livre qui a été
voté à l'unanimité
je trouve que c'est une séquence
sénatoriales importante que nous
traversons autour et en faveur du livre
et de la lecture publique
en deux jours le sénat sera honoré en
débattant pleinement de l'ensemble de la
chaîne du livre ce qui témoigne une
nouvelle fois de notre engagement mes
chers collègues sans faille en faveur de
la culture et de toutes celles et tous
ceux qui la font vivre et à ce titre là
je vous en remercie très sincèrement
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent à madame roselyne bachelot
ministre de la culture
madame la présidente je salue également
le président de la commission laurent
lafon madame la rapporteure et auteur
des textes chercher lire aubert vdab les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
je suis heureuse de vous retrouver
aujourd'hui pour évoquer la politique
des bibliothèques
après avoir débattu hier de plusieurs
sujets importants pour les acteurs de la
chaîne du livre
grâce à la proposition de loi de laure
darcos les quinze ni la bibliothèque
française constitue le premier
équipement culturel de notre pays près
de 13000 collectivités territoriales
communes intercommunalités départements
font vivre ces lieux de culture et
d'éducation sur tout territoire
elle consacre chaque année près de 1,7
milliard d'euros à ce service public
grâce à elle plus de 85% des français
ont accès à une bibliothèque dans leur
commune l'état prend part à cet effort
en faveur des bibliothèques et de la
lecture publique
outre les bibliothèques universitaires
hilaire deux villes y attaquent national
que sont la bibliothèque nationale de
france et la bibliothèque publique
d'information
il accompagne aussi les collectivités
territoriales pour moderniser leurs
bibliothèques et maintenir la vitalité
de la lecture publique
le partenariat noué entre les
collectivités territoriales et l'état
autour des bibliothèques est remarquable
et ce quinquennat restera comme un
moment particulièrement fort de cette
relation sur la base du diagnostic posé
par erik orsenna ci faisait allusion
madame la rapporteure en 2018
les collectivités territoriales et
l'état vont renforcer leur collaboration
pour étendre les horaires d'ouverture
des bibliothèques pour diversifier leurs
missions pour accompagner la formation
des professionnels grâce aux plans pour
les bibliothèques qui en est issu l'état
a les a accrues des moyens alloués aux
collectivités au travers de la dotation
générale de décentralisation du plan de
relance et d'une politique de
contractualisation renforcer une vraie
dynamique est née et j'espère qu'elle se
poursuivra les résultats sont là
entre 2016 et aujourd'hui les horaires
ont augmenté de 8 heures 30 par semaine
dans les 710 communes dont la médiatique
a étendu ses horaires plus de 11,3
millions de français peuvent ainsi
bénéficier d'un service accrue notamment
dans les territoires les plus fragiles
les bibliothèques ont été parmi les
seuls établissements culturels à rester
largement ouverts durant la crise
sanitaire
puisqu'ils n'ont interrompu leurs
services que quelques semaines au
printemps et à l'automne 2020 lors des
premier et deuxième confinement ce
moment bibliothèque trouve aujourd'hui
sa concrétisation sur le plan
législatives
grâce à votre initiative madame la
sénatrice sylvie robert je salue votre
engagement sans faille en faveur des
bibliothèques
puisque vous aviez déjà oeuvré à la
création 2016 du dispositif de soutien à
l'extension de leurs horaires
d'ouverture
vous l'avez rappelé le secteur des
bibliothèques n'échappe pas au droit
mais vous avez relevé la faiblesse de la
présence des bibliothèques dans notre
corpus législatif
oui c'est vrai le code du patrimoine
accorde 60 articles de l'oise archives
30 au musée et cinq aux bibliothèques la
pauvreté relative de ce cadre
législatives a suscité depuis des
décennies nombre de débats parmi des
professionnels sur la nécessité ou non
d'une loi sur les bibliothèques
elle a conduit à plusieurs tentatives de
légiférer qui n'ont pas abouti je crois
que venus aujourd'hui le moment de faire
pleinement entrer les bibliothèques dans
le droit avec un texte qui à mes yeux
présente au moins quatre avant ce
premier mérite du texte il est
fondamental de rappeler que les missions
culturelles éducatives sociales ou
ludiques des bibliothèques s'inscrivent
dans le respect des principes de
pluralisme des courants d'idées et
d'opinions et de neutralité du service
public je crois que la période nous
invite à cette exigence
plus que jamais les bibliothèques
doivent demeurer des espaces de liberté
des lieux de respiration démocratique
leurs professionnels doivent être
protégés de la censure comme de toute
pression politique religieuse ou sociale
leur collection doivent refléter la
diversité
des opinions deuxième mérite les
bibliothèques doivent rester accessibles
à tous librement et gratuitement
il est important que la loi entérine un
principe qui fait consensus et constitue
l'une des conditions cardinal du succès
des bibliothèques troisième mérite la
loi accompagne la montée en puissance
des collaborations entre collectivités
territoriales tout en respectant leur
libre administration et en réaffirmant
le rôle ô combien essentiel des
bibliothèques départementales en soutien
aux petites bibliothèques notamment
rurales enfin ces avancées prennent la
forme d'un texte concis et ramassé il
est de nature j'en suis convaincu à
faire l'objet d'un consensus à l'image
de celui qui existe autour du rôle des
bibliothèques
si chère à nos concitoyens pour toutes
ces raisons le gouvernement soutient
sans réserve l'esprit et la lettre de la
proposition de loi de sylvie robert
relatives aux bibliothèques ce carrefour
de tous les rêves de l'humanité 10 et
julien green et au développement de la
lecture publique et vous pouvez compter
sur mon engagement pour permettre
rapidement la poursuite du processus
législatif de ce texte
vous voilà rassurés chaire sylvie robert
merci à tous et à toutes
merci madame la ministre dans la suite
de la discussion générale la parole est
à présent à madame monique de marco du
groupe des écologistes
vous avez quatre minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
mais sa collègue
notre pays compte aujourd'hui plus de
16500 bibliothèque
le réseau de lecture publique ses
considérants ne considérablement
développée grâce à la décentralisation
elles ont élargi leur champ de
compétence proposant des plates formes
en ligne de consultation outre le livre
qui reste leur coeur d'activité
les bibliothèques et médiathèques sont
des portes ouvertes sous de nombreuses
expressions culturelles musique cinéma
arts visuels compte photographie ce sont
des lieux d'échangés de rencontres mais
aussi des lieux d'utilité sociale
inclusif et solidaire mais dans le même
temps le cadre juridique dans lesquelles
les bibliothèques territoriale
s'inscrivent est insuffisant même s'il
existe un ensemble de textes
réglementaires de jurisprudence
il n'existe aucun texte de loi
établissant une définition claire et
précisant le rôle de ces temples de
l'information elles sont notamment
absente du code du patrimoine
aucune mention n'est faite seule la
bibliothèque nationale de france et la
bibliothèque publique d'information sont
placés sous la tutelle directe du
diagnostic de la culture et dispose
d'une législation propre
les agents de bibliothèques attendait
avec impatience une évolution de notre
corpus juridique et la reconnaissance du
travail qu'ils font au quotidien ce sont
grâce à eux que nous du biotech ont su
innover se réinventer dans le but de
sauvegarder cette richesse qu'est la
lecture publique
je remercie donc ma collègue chili
robert autrice et rapporteur de ce texte
qui participent au développement de
l'accès à la culture en france
cette proposition de loi réaffirme
également trois grands principes
essentiels la liberté d'accès aux
bibliothèques municipales et
intercommunales sur tout le territoire
français
le principe de la gratuité d'accès aux
collections et documents présents dans
les bibliothèques territoriale et enfin
le pluralisme des collections enfin de
respecter les opinions de sac une île
chacun et de réaffirmer la neutralité
nos services publics mentionnées à
l'article 5 ce principe s'inspire du
manifeste de l'unesco
qui rappelle des collections les
services ne doivent être soumis à une
forme quelconque de censure idéologique
politique religieuse ni à des pressions
commerciales
je salue la volonté de l'article 12
voulant limiter la destruction
intempestives de milliers de livres
chaque année après désherbage en donnant
la possibilité aux bibliothèques
territoriale de cd des livres à des
associations caritatives
cet article pose les bases légales un
principe que je défendrai toujours ne
jamais détruire un livre c'est
d'ailleurs pour renforcer ce principe et
ouvrir le débat sur les dons que nous
avons déposé deux amendements
pourquoi parce qu'en réalité trop peu
d'associations les moyens d'organiser un
plan de redistribution à grande et
celles des livres et documents font
encore face au risque d'être détruit
après désherbage de ce fait certains
bibliothèques font d'ores et déjà
cession de documents à des entreprises
de l'économie sociale et solidaire ou à
des organismes d'accueil communautaire
et d'activités solidaires comme emmaüs
je tiens à saluer le travail de nos
collectivités qui doivent faire toujours
mieux
en vain encore moins de moyens
financiers la lecture publique n'y fait
pas exception
nous espérons que le projet de loi 4e
dire non mais 3ds qui prévoit le
transfert de certaines compétences aux
collectivités locales sera l'occasion de
développer la responsabilité de nos
départements et d'accroître leurs moyens
dans le développement de la lecture
publique
cette proposition de loi répond aux
enjeux et aux problématiques qui
s'imposa lecture publique et aux
bibliothèques
elle fait le pas verni bibliothèque
inclusive gratuite et informer dans le
choix de ses collections
le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoires votre a chaleureusement en
faveur de ce texte je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent un monsieur julien bargeton du
groupe r des pays pour quatre minutes
madame la ministre
même la rapporteure et aux tris du la
proposition de loi monsieur le président
chers collègues
évidemment notre groupe s'associe aux
félicitations et votera ce texte les
bibliothèques
c'est le premier équipement culturel de
france
seize mille cinq cents établissements et
12 millions d'usagers
c'est donc le premier équipement en
matière de culture
le rapport qui a été cité de messieurs
eric orsenna et noël corbin de 2018
montré que 40% des français fréquenter
une bibliothèque dans l'année mais que
seul 50% d'entre eux il y emprunter un
livre ce qu'ils montrent d'ailleurs la
diversification des activités des
bibliothèques depuis longtemps moi je me
souviens avoir fréquenté dans ma
jeunesse la bibliothèque faidherbe dans
le 11e arrondissement pour écouter des
contes c'est ce qui permet l'accès au
livre d'ailleurs puisqu'il y avait comme
dans beaucoup de biotech encore
aujourd'hui en france des comptes qui
est élu pour finalement et bien faire
accéder aux livres les jeunes enfants et
aujourd'hui on va chercher parfois et
bien un accueil du café le wifi etc
des lectures publiques bref c'est un
lieu indispensable
il ya une extraordinaire adhésion des
français en bibliothèque
mais il y avait rien qui encadraient et
ce texte est très bienvenue
il n'y avait pas de loi cadre pas de
définition non plus et trois acteurs
décentralisée qui sont impliqués les
communes les établissements publics de
coopération intercommunale les
départements sans que leur rôle soit
précisée demain d'ailleurs peut-être
faudra-t-il aller plus loin et notamment
inscrire comme compétences obligatoires
des départements le sujet des
bibliothèques départementales
il ya donc un consensus qui a
immergés je remercie le gouvernement
d'avoir décidé la procédure accélérée
sur ce texte la commission de l'avoir
votée à l'unanimité et ce consensus
d'ailleurs rejoint celui d'hier à propos
des librairies indépendantes
je n'y vois pas une coïncidence de date
mais bien que le livre rassemble et si
le livre rassemble c'est parce que les
bibliothèques
c'est le lieu ce sont le lieu du lien le
lieu du lien entre les personnes entre
les gens et puis le lien entre passé et
présent et aussi l'avenir je voudrais
ici citer un passage de la recherche de
proust c'est grâce il parlement de
l'oubli de la mémoire
c'est grâce à cet oubli seul que nous
pouvons de temps en temps à autre
retrouvez lettre que nous fûmes au grand
jour de la mémoire habituels les images
du passé pallice peu à peu ses faces il
ne reste plus rien d'elle nous ne le
retrouverons plus ou plutôt nous ne les
retrouvons nous ne les retrouverez rond
plus si quelques mots n'avaient été
soigneusement enfermé dans l'oubli de
même qu'on dépose à la bibliothèque un
exemplaire d'un livre qui sans cela
risquerait de devenir introuvable nos
bibliothèques publiques sont donc bien
les gardiennes de la mémoire mais aussi
le lieu du lien aujourd'hui agent un
rôle patrimoniale et elles ont un rôle
dans l'actualité ce sont à la fois des
lieux de vie des lieux des changes et
des lieux de mémoire
c'est en cela qu'elles sont extrêmement
importantes cette proposition de loi
acte intelligemment de l'évolution leur
usage et accompagne leur mutation
c'est pourquoi nous la voterons et je
finirai en citant évidemment parce que
ça a été déjà le cas umberto eco comment
ne pas le citer le nom de la rose où le
personnage et la bibliothèque avec ce
fameux bibliothécaire aveugle nous
sommes dans un monastère mais c'est bien
une bibliothèque dont il s'agit une
abbaye et subit le caire avec qui
s'appellerait des burgos est en réalité
une allusion à borgès dans le nom
d'ailleurs il voilà ce qu'écrit umberto
eco la bibliothèque se défend tout seul
insondable comme la vérité qu'elle
héberge trompeuse comme le mensonge
qu'elle conserve puis avoir quelques
mensonges d'un iota
labyrinthe spirituel c'est aussi un
labyrinthe terrestre madame la
rapporteure rentrons dans le labyrinthe
pour mieux s'en sortir
merci beaucoup merci chers collègues la
parole est à présent à monsieur bernard
fialaire du groupe
rds ce pot 4 minutes chaque collègue la
présidente madame la présidente madame
le ministre
adam la rapporteur sur le président de
la commission mais chers collègues pour
gaston bachelard le paradis à n'en pas
douter n'est qu'une immense bibliothèque
en bon radical comprendrait que si
j'aspire au paradis c'est sur terre que
je veux y accéder aussi je m'inscris
dans cette pensée qui témoigne de la
valeur civilisatrice essentiel dans nos
vies de tels lieux culturels
la france terre de littérature bénéficie
d'une large couverture de bibliothèques
sur tout son territoire permettant un
surcroît de fréquentation au sein de ces
lieux culturels clés ainsi 89% de la
population française a accès à un lieu
de culture de lecture dans sur ce dans
sa commune et plus de 27 millions de
français fréquentent ces équipements
culturels en grande partie grâce à la
diversification de leurs activités
les bibliothèques centres de plus en
plus au coeur de la cité participe
activement politiques publiques de lutte
contre l'illettrisme ou la fracture
numérique sur la base du rapport orsenna
corbin pourra parler le gouvernement
avait déjà entendu adopté et étendre les
horaires des bibliothèques publiques
afin d'en faire un troisième lieu entre
le travail et la maison
les bibliothèques sont un pôle des
changes et de sociabilité au coeur des
activités quotidiennes des citoyens
mais au delà de la seule problématique
des horaires il était tant que
législateur saisissent davantage cet
enjeu primordial pour le tissu culturel
avec plus de 16000 établissements en
effet et à la différence des autres
domaines patrimoniaux les bêtes les
bibliothèques n'ont jamais fait l'objet
d'une loi cadre l'article
premier apporte une définition bien
venue des missions de service public de
la bibliothèque parmi lesquels la
conservation et la communication des
oeuvres qu'il s'agisse de libre de cd ou
de dvd par exemple mais aussi la
contribution progrès de la connaissance
et de la recherche à destination du
public l'a proposé la présente
proposition de loi inscrit les principes
de liberté et gratuité d'accès aux
bibliothèques municipales et
intercommunales
on paye pas droit d'entrer au paradis et
consacrer le pluralisme et le
renouvellement des collections
enfin la proposition de loi conforte les
bibliothèques départementales dans leur
rôle d'assistance et de soutien à celles
des communes et des opc c'est dans le
respect de la libre administration des
collectivités
l'auteur de la proposition de loi a
utilement tracer un cas de moins
contraignant et plus respectueux des
compétences locales
c'est ainsi que l'article cette charge
les bibliothèques d'établir les
orientations générales de leur politique
documentaire orientations que
l'assemblée délibérante seraient incités
à débattre enfin la loi étend le
bénéfice du concours particulier
bibliothèque au sein de la dotation
générale de décentralisation à
l'ensemble des opci des groupements de
collectivités et d'egypte et et non plus
seulement aux communes
cet accroissement du soutien financier
de l'état favorisera inévitablement le
développement de la lecture publique
dans tous les territoires
pour toutes ces raisons sur votre avec
du groupe avec l' enthousiasme
c'est indispensable proposition de loi
améliorée par le travail en commissions
et vous remercie madame le prix merci
chers collègues je passe la parole à
présent mais c'est jérémy baty du groupe
communiste
bonsoir madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
la lecture est à l'esprit ce que
l'exercice et au corps ces mots je les
tiennes de joseph addison l'intellectuel
anglais qui s'opposent à la monarchie
absolue britannique
car en effet c'est bien accédant à la
connaissance notamment par la lecture
qu'on se construit une âme de citoyens
ce n'est d'ailleurs pas un hasard si le
premier réflexe d'un régime autoritaire
et systématiquement veut s'attaquer aux
livres et à leur accès c'est vrai dans
les anciens régimes salle est encore
malheureusement aujourd'hui en salles et
bibliothèques publiques sont la cheville
ouvrière de cette politique de la
connaissance
elles sont celles qui pour tous les
citoyens quelles que soient leurs
conditions participe à la
démocratisation de la démocratie pour
reprendre des termes détiennent balibar
mais cette mission civique fait porter
sur les épaules des bibliothèques de
lourdes responsabilités la première
c'est celle de l'accès au bâtiment oui
mais aussi à leurs trésors
c'est dans cette optique il est
essentiel de valoriser les très
nombreuses actions des bibliothèques
pour d'une part attirer des personnes
qui se sentent illégitime qui se
sentiraient légitime ou pas assez doté à
les fréquenter et d'autres pas faire de
la médiation culturelle
à ce titre les actions d'accueil des
publics scolaires comme cela se fait
dans de nombreuses villes notamment à
marseille participe pleinement la
formation citoyenne des enfants
la seconde c'est celle de grandir des
contenus divers de garantir pardon des
contenus divers et pluraliste on a vu
récemment dans certaines villes la
tentation est grande pour des majorités
municipales de restreindre les contenus
bibliothécaire à ce qui va dans leur
sens nous devons lutter contre cette
tentation qui restreint le champ des
possibles et contribué à assécher le
débat démocratique alors que livrent une
uniformisation des modes de pensée
guette le service public bibliothécaire
a une responsabilité toute particulière
nous devons donc l'en préservé et lui
donner les moyens d'exercer sa mission
mais les bibliothèques sont aujourd'hui
bien plus que des bâtiments je le disais
de notre temps comme certains
serez tenté de le faire croire l'arrivée
massive des nouvelles oeuvres
culturelles au sein des bibliothèques
doit être accompagnée et encouragée
musique et films sont autant de contenu
qui d'une part attire les jeunes et
d'autre part les formes
intellectuellement
de la même manière il est malheureux que
certaines communes fassent le choix de
couper leurs abonnements des journaux
alors même que les bibliothèques sont
des lieux pour s'informer notamment pour
celles et ceux qui ne peuvent pas se
permettre de s'abonner un journal cette
proposition de loi doit donner les
outils nécessaires aux bibliothécaires
pour se protéger de ces manoeuvres qui
vont à l'encontre de l'essence même des
bibliothèques à savoir donner aux
citoyens et aux citoyens la possibilité
de se construire un rapport au monde qui
lui soit propre et lui donner les moyens
de faire des choix éclairés en fait on
ne peut pas parler des bibliothèques
sans évoquer l'espace de vie qu'elle
constitue expositions conférences
rencontres initiative des dalles
exercice des droits que c'est internet
c'est maison du savoir permettent aux
citoyens parfois isolés de s'intégrer à
la communauté accès à la connaissance et
au divertissement émancipation
construction citoyenne et intégration
sociale
ce n'est pas un autre but que
poursuivent et la révolution
nationalisant les bibliothèques
ecclésiastique plus en constituant les
collections publiques dès 1790 si comme
le pense et la romancière
mary higgins clark les bibliothèques
sont 1 semaine vers le futur l'absence
de lois cadres les reconnaissant est une
erreur que nous allons réparer et je
tenais à remercier notre collègue sylvie
robert chose que nous pourrons faire dès
à présent grâce à cette proposition que
notre groupe soutiendra sans aucune
réserve
merci merci chers collègues
j'invite maintenant pierre antoine lévy
du groupe union centriste à prendre la
parole pour 4 minutes chers collègues
trois minutes même pardon
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame le rapporteur autour de cette
proposition de loi cherche yves robert
monsieur le président de la commission
la culture mais chaque collègue en
politique il faut apprécier les concerts
de louanges
les grandes bien sûr cuménique les
moments où tout le monde est d'accord
quand ils sont rares d'examen de la
présente proposition de loi en est un
car oui s'il ya bien une chose que la
crise de la copie 19 nous a enseigné
c'est notre besoin collectif de culture
ces mois de fermeture de l'ensemble des
lieux culturels ont été particulièrement
difficile pour bien des français
je me félicite donc que la proposition
de loi de notre collègue didier robert
arrive au moment opportun
à l'heure où nous pouvons enfin
retrouver nos espaces de culture qui
font vivre nos villes nos villages et
nos territoires
s'il faut apprécier ces moments c'est
aussi en les prenant avec lucidité nous
nous retrouvons aujourd'hui autour de
quelques principes auxquels nul ne
pourrait trouver quoi que ce soit à
redire qui est content des bibliothèques
qui pourrait défendre l'idée que leur
accès doit cesser d'être libres ou
devrait devenir payant
quelle collectivité prendrait cette
décision politiquement suicidaire
seuls les partisans d'une taxe sur l'air
que l'on respire pour s opposer à de
tels principes talent et ont qu une loi
pour ça je me pose simplement la
question
ce texte contribue peut-être à
d'inflation législatives mais je
reconnais dans le travail de sylvie
robert une consécration des
bibliothèques en gravant dans le marbre
ce inter certains principes généraux
consensuel qui pourrait avoir cependant
quelques conséquences qui le sont moins
l'article 5 en particulier mais cher
parce qu'il énonce le principe de la
pluralité idéologique dans un contexte
où la pensée des colonials et la cancel
culture sont tentés de faire disparaître
tous les ouvrages qui ne correspondent
pas à leurs positions la liberté
d'expression n'est pas négociable
c'est pourquoi j'y adhère pleinement à
cet article mais il faut bien comprendre
que ce faisant ce sont les opinions les
moins consensuel que l'on défend je
m'interroge d'ailleurs sur
l'articulation entre cet article
l'article 7 qui prévoit que les
bibliothèques présentent leurs
orientations de politique documentaire
aux assemblées locales
de la politique municipale dans la
politique documentaire des bibliothèques
est elle une bonne chose
ne risque-t-on pas de basculer dans une
politisation trop poussée des lieux de
lecture par delà les dispositions
concrètes du présent texte nous donne
l'occasion de nous interroger sur
l'avenir des bibliothèques elles se sont
déjà énormément modernisé pour devenir
des espaces multimédias des zones de
combat aux kings des terres de
respiration sociale c'est ce mouvement
qu'il nous faut accompagner dans nos
collectivités et cela ne passera pas
forcément par la loi oui ces éléments
vous aurez compris mes chers collègues
que le groupe de l'union centriste votre
attrait favorablement et avec grand
plaisir
cette proposition de loi je vous
remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à présent madame l os avec
deux groupes les républicains pour 8
minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteure monsieur le
président mes chers collègues la
richesse que constitue les livres et la
lecture est inestimable
ils sont source de savoir de
connaissances et peut-être plus que tout
source de liberté d'émancipation et de
créativité
ils sont à l'honneur depuis deux jours
au sénat grâce à l'étude de deux textes
importants pour lesquels je tiens à
remercier les collègues pour leur
travail et leur engagement depuis des
années afin que ces propositions de loi
voit le jour hier nous votions à
l'unanimité le texte de laure darcos
mettant en avant la filière
professionnelle du livre et nos
librairies
si importante à la vie culturelle de nos
communes aujourd'hui nous examinons le
texte initié par sylvie robert relatifs
aux bibliothèques et au développement de
la lecture publique
cette proposition de loi répond à une
réelle attente nous avons pu le
constater lors des auditions et son
accueil très positif s'explique par le
fait qu'elle vient combler plusieurs
lacunes et actes et les mutations qu'ont
connu ces lieux de culture indispensable
76% des français estiment que les
bibliothèques sont utiles à tous et 20%
de la population considère les
bibliothèques comme un équipement
indispensable
cette proposition de loi adapte les
dispositions existantes au paysage
territorial autour de trois grands
principes qu'il était important de
consacrer afin de donner un cadre
législatif précis et ambitieux aux
bibliothèques tout en respectant la
libre administration des collectivités
ces principes ont été rappelés c'est la
liberté d'accès aux bibliothèques
municipales et intercommunales la
gratuité de l'accès aux espaces publics
et la gratuité de la consultation sur
place mais également le pluralisme des
collections afin notamment d'éviter
toute censure les enjeux auxquels ce
texte répond avait déjà été mis en
évidence dans votre rapport de 2015
madame la rapporteure ainsi que dans le
rapport
orsenna de 2018 dans notre pays
des lois existent sur les musées sur les
archives par exemple mais jamais jusqu'à
ce jour il n'y avait eu de loi cadre sur
les bibliothèques pour la première fois
donc ce texte
donne une définition de ce qu'est une
bibliothèque à travers son article 1er
en cela il vient consacrer les
bibliothèques en tant que premier
équipement culturel en france par leur
maillage territorial dense les
bibliothèques sont la première porte
d'un égal accès pour tous à
l'apprentissage mais également à la
découverte de la lecture avec tout ce
que cela comprend la lutte contre
l'illettrisme l'ouverture sur le monde
l'exercice de la citoyenneté le
développement de l'esprit critique mais
également l'épanouissement de l'individu
70 % des communes de plus de 2000
habitants ont une bibliothèque et nous
voyons de plus en plus de projets de
boîtes à livres notamment émergé dans
les petites communes en france on compte
16500 équipements de lecture publique
soit autant que deux points postaux
l'émission des bibliothèques
départementales sont elles aussi
définissent dans ce texte à l'article 9
afin de confirmer leur rôle essentiel et
nécessaire de soutien mais également de
coordination et d'ingénierie dans le
développement de la lecture publique
notamment dans les zones rurales en tant
que sénatrice du bas-rhin
je prends pour exemple la bibliothèque
d'alsace créé dès 1946 dont le bon
fonctionnement et l'engouement qu'elle
suscite témoigne de la forte utilité de
ces bibliothèques départementales
les chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes dans le
réseau des bibliothèques d'alsace parce
que ce ne sont pas moins de six sites
700 mille ouvrages mis à la disposition
des 288 bibliothèque 60 services
proposés et plus de 3000 bénévoles qui
sont investis aujourd'hui les
bibliothèques sont protéiformes et offre
des services qui s'adressent à toute la
population petit et grands en évolution
permanente
elles ont su rebondir et se transformer
pour relever les défis socio éducatifs
et culturels
elles ne sont plus seulement un lieu de
savoir et d'études
elles ont de plus en plus une vocation
sociale et permettre la rencontre de
toutes les générations et de tous les
milieux socioprofessionnels les enjeux
d'une bibliothèque publique en 2021
sont nombreux et multiples notamment un
enjeu très fort des ressources
numériques et de la médiation culturelle
ainsi que l'éducation aux médias qui est
une thématique qui se développe très
fortement mais plus généralement
d'autres enjeux sont inhérents aux
bibliothèques publiques les enjeux
socio-économiques les bibliothèques
lutte contre la fracture numérique et
développe l'engagement citoyen par le
bénévolat elle offre des services
diversifiés
le livre constitue par exemple un outil
de culture comme lien entre les parents
et les enfants également les enjeux
éducatifs 15% des enfants n'ont
malheureusement pas de livres chez eux
et la pratique culturelle de la lecture
contribuer là aussi à la formation de
l'individu
les bibliothèques ont développé de
nombreux partenariats et projets avec
les écoles avec la sphère éducative et
ce pour encourager l'apprentissage et
les joies de la lecture dès la
maternelle également les enjeux
culturels avec des contenus multimédias
sélectionné renouveler valoriser ainsi
que des animations proposées
ponctuellement et une offre de proximité
structuré du point lecture jusqu'à la
médiathèque
enfin enjeux de développement local les
bibliothèques sont un partenaire central
pour beaucoup de chants de politiques
publiques est un vecteur d'attractivité
de nos territoires
véritable service public de proximité et
parfois seul équipement culturel de la
commune les bibliothèques sont des lieux
de vie auquel les élus et nos
concitoyens sont particulièrement
attachés inscrire les bibliothèques dans
la loi c'est également reconnaître le
rôle de l'ensemble des personnes qui
travaillent afin de les protéger
bibliothécaires bénévoles étudiants dont
le travail et l'engagement au service
des autres sont à saluer cette
proposition de loi à vertus incitatives
permet ainsi d'actes et ses mutations et
l'évolution des missions des
bibliothèques pour permettre un meilleur
accès à la culture et au savoir
je tiens pour finir
à remercier une nouvelle fois
l'investissement et l'engagement de
notre collègue sylvie robert afin de
consacrer ce sujet ô combien important
pour notre territoire à un niveau
législatif pour toutes ces raisons et
vous l'aurez bien compris notre groupe
votera avec enthousiasme pour ce texte
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues
la parole est à présent à à monsieur
joël guerriau du groupe les indépendants
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président la commission
madame la rapporteure chers collègues
depuis andré malraux la politique
culturelle de la france a pour premier
objectif l'accessibilité des oeuvres au
plus grand nombre et l'encouragement de
la création
l'accès à la culture au sens large est
l'une des principales vocations des
bibliothèques
cette proposition de loi s'intéresse
plus spécifiquement biotech des
collectivités territoriales et
représente la première initiative visant
à instaurer un cadre juridique pour ces
lieux de culture indispensable à la vie
locale
la france s'était rappelée compte seize
mille cinq cents lieux de lecture
publique accueillant près de 27 millions
de lecteurs chaque année relais de
culture mais aussi de lien social
leur mission est d' en actions
s'inscrivent pleinement dans les grands
enjeux contemporains 7 % des français
sont encore en situation d'illettrisme
soit 2 5 millions de personnes et 20 %
des français seraient concernés par
l'électro nisme si les bibliothèques
représente un levier contre
l'analphabétisme
elle contribue aussi à combler la
fracture numérique territoriale et
générationnelle et offre désormais des
services étendus de l'éducation
artistique à la maîtrise des outils
numériques dans les milieux ruraux et
les banlieues les bibliothèques sont de
précieux relais de l'état sur le
territoire et remplissent des missions
aussi diverses qui est essentielle pour
un public souvent isolées socialement
aide aux démarches administratives
accueil des migrants accompagnement des
personnes âgées dépendantes des détenus
encore des personnes marginalisées
aussi ces lieux de culture sont aussi
des lieux d'intégration participant
pleinement à la réparation du lien
social
cette proposition de loi fixe les grands
principes qui régissent les missions et
l'organisation des bibliothèques de nos
collectivités et favorise le
développement de la politique de lecture
publique
cependant nous devons être attentifs à
ne pas fixer un cadre trop contraignant
pour les élus locaux en particulier
concernant leur liberté d'organisation
et de gestion de ces lieux de culture
en effet il faut analyser le principe de
liberté d'accès fixées à l'article 2
avec précaution les collectivités
doivent pouvoir organiser le
fonctionnement des bibliothèques
notamment en matière de réservation des
plages horaires
pour des publics particuliers de fixer
actions de jauge de fréquentation ou
encore de respecte de respect de la
tranquillité des lieux
d'autre part l'article 3 consacre le
principe de gratuité d'accès aux
bibliothèques des communes et
intercommunalités
je suis favorable sur le principe de la
gratuité de la consultation sur place
mais je considère que la mairie doit
pouvoir conditionné l'emprunt de livres
une inscription un abonnement si elle le
souhaite en effet les collectivités
locales financent leurs bibliothèques et
médiathèques
il appartient donc aux élus locaux
d'adapter les conditions d'accès des
grille de tarification de l'emprunt de
livres mais ceci n'est pas
contradictoire avec ses propositions de
loi je tenais simplement à le rappeler
ce texte présente donc des avancées que
nous approuvons mais pour autant
d'autres progrès sont envisagées et je
pense en particulier à l'encouragement à
la création
en effet je voudrais attirer votre
attention il convient de souligner
madame la ministre que 15% des auteurs
professionnels en france perçoivent
moins de 400 euros par mois dans lorsque
la création d'un artiste dans le domaine
musical est diffusée dans un cadre
public
la sacem impose à la collectivité de
verser des droits d'auteur
pourquoi les livres empruntés dans le
cadre de bibliothèques ne font pas
l'objet d'un comptage par auteurs il
faut deux ans pour réaliser une bande
dessinée
il serait logique que ces derniers
auteurs perçoivent ainsi que l'éditeur
une juste rémunération du travail qui
est très souvent fastidieux et
permettant donc ainsi d'encourager la
création
je rappelle que ses auteurs pour
beaucoup d'entre eux vivent dans des
conditions très difficiles et je pense
que c'est un sujet qu'il faudra tôt ou
tard traiter cette proposition de loi
est une excellente initiative représente
comme j'ai dit de nombreuses avancées
c'est pourquoi le groupe les
indépendants la trouve et votre à ce
texte merci merci chers collègues
la parole est à présent monsieur david
assouline du groupe socialiste
vous avez la parole pour six minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame
madame la ministre monsieur le président
chers collègues rapporteur mes chers
collègues
marcel proust disait que la lecture est
une amitié
cette amitié plus de 6 millions de
français l'ont avec leurs bibliothèques
et par la bibliothèque pour la lecture
en étant inscrits à l'une d'entre elles
et en ayant emprunté 247 millions de
livres en 2019 avec plus de 16000
bibliothèque en france elle est le lieu
culturel de référence pour les français
de par sa présence sur l'ensemble du
territoire ce service public est
essentiel d nécessaire de le valoriser
et de le renforcer et il méritait une
loi cadre et donc ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui même si nous sommes peu
nombreux
s'il peut en parle c'est un acte
historique puisque ça n'a jamais été
fait et s'il y a un parlementaire ou
l'occurrence une parlementaire qui
méritait d'associer son nom à cette
initiative historique
c'est sylvie robert qui est depuis de
longues années est engagée dans ce
travers cet espace arrive dans nos
quotidiens dès le plus jeune âge à
l'école il deviendra ensuite le parcours
un rendez vous régulier pour les enfants
souvent avec un une documentaliste -
documentaliste passionnés killer
inculquera une base solide pour
comprendre le fonctionnement d'une
bibliothèque et y découvrir le plaisir
de la lecture
celle ci sera présente aussi tout au
long du parcours scolaire le primaire à
l'université elle accompagne élèves dans
son apprentissage mais également dans
ses loisirs est sa citoyenneté lieu
convivial d'échangés de culture est
évidemment de lecture la bibliothèque
est un espace où les barrières
générationnelle et sociale disparaissent
pour laisser un plaisir commun la
rencontre le partage et la découverte
que nous c'est d'ailleurs pour cette
raison qui les font
un mental que ce lieu soit accessible à
toutes et à tous et ce gratuitement pour
qu'il soit le plus ouvert possible
je veux aussi saluer le travail
formidable réalisé par toutes ces
bibliothèques air archivistes
documentalistes passionnés qui ont tant
de plaisir à recommander des livres
selon les envies de chacune et chacun
est proposé une sélection d'oeuvres de
qualité
les agents travaillant en bibliothèque
ont un rôle fondamental
nous nous devons de les soutenir de les
protéger pour offrir un service public
de qualité
les bibliothèques ont été délaissées
assez longtemps tout comme pour les
autres services publics les pratiques
les missions et les besoins changent et
il est nécessaire de s'y adapter
trop peu de loi où était discuté pour
moderniser ou valoriser ses sept acteurs
de la culture et aujourd'hui il y à
cette initiative qui vient réparer aussi
cet oubli ou ce peu d'intérêt manifesté
par le législateur je pense notamment à
l'adaptation et à l'extension des
horaires d'ouverture au public qui
permet l'accès à ce service public aux
plus grandes eaux un effort mon
négligeable a été également réalisée
pour soutenir le développement des
missions davantage les connu pour les
français par les agents des
bibliothèques
vous l'aurez compris les travaux menés
sur les bibliothèques et la lecture
publique ne sont pas restés lettre morte
ils ont trouvé une concrétisation et des
évolutions qui nécessitait toutefois
d'être précisées à fermi et c'est bien
l'objectif principal de cette loi que
l'on doit saluer tout d'abord les
principes de gratuité et de liberté
d'accès aux bibliothèques municipales et
intercommunales dans la loi sont
fondamentales dans un pays démocratique
comme le nôtre
la bibliothèque est l'une des pierres
angulaires de la démocratisation et de
l'accès à la culture pour tous c'est
également une des premières rencontres
avec la lecture pour beaucoup de
français
et il est essentiel d'inscrire dans la
loi ces principes comme immuable
nous devons nous battre pour prohiber
tout développement de pratiques qui
viserait alors restreint ou à le rendre
payant le pluralisme également est un
élément préciser dans la loi
et à l'heure actuelle et dans ce monde
tel qu'il va
ce pluralisme n'est pas un luxe c'est
une nécessité absolue à l'heure
notamment de l'uniformisation des
grandes plateformes descente verticale
de même contenu sans choix possibles
dans cette diversité qui fait la
richesse de la culture et de l'éducation
les bibliothèques aussi favorise
l'exercice de la liberté de l'esprit
critique ça a été rappelé et dans la
situation que nous rappelle l'actualité
de façon brutale tous les jours où on
est devant des vérités alternative des
thèses complotistes des religieux
extrémistes qui veulent endoctrinés et
d'autres extrémisme idéologique l'esprit
critique se former à la liberté à la
raison trouve son support premier et je
n'en ai pas encore trouvé d'autres
meilleurs dans la lecture dans le livre
et c'est aussi une des raisons
essentielles de cette fois je n'ai pas
décliner ce que tout le monde a bien
décliné ici puisque c'est une loi
consensuelle
je veux finir en disant que les français
sont attachés à ce service public nous
devons lui donner les moyens de ses
ambitions afin de lui permettre au
rayonnement qu'il mérite
c'est pourquoi notre groupe bien entendu
soutiendra cette proposition de loi de
notre collègue sylvie robert avec
enthousiasme
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues de votre
enthousiasme j'appelle maintenant
monsieur philippe folliot et du groupe
union centriste pour 3 minutes chers
collègues
merci dans la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission madame la rapporteure mes
chers collègues
il est des inventions
il est des techniques qui change le
monde
nous allons bientôt fêter les plus de
450 470 ans qu'une invention technique
l'imprimerie a bouleversé le monde parce
qu'elle a permis la diffusion de la
connaissance
elle a permis la démocratisation de la
les lumières seront à à certains égards
les enfants de cette évolution technique
et à l'heure où nous vivons d'autres
révolutions techniques dont peut-être à
l'avenir nous montrera démontrera quels
sont outre les ronds été aussi
importante que celle de l'imprimerie
nous avons la numérisation qui
aujourd'hui envahi notre quotidien mais
surtout l'intelligence artificielle qui
va bouleverser bien des choses bien des
domaines bien des secteurs et par
rapport à cela
finalement la question qui pourrait être
posée
c'est dire est ce que le livre a de
l'avenir
est-ce que les bibliothèques ont de
à cette question je réponds
comme chacune et chacun d'entre nous oui
parce que c'est un socle et c'est sur ce
socle que l'on pourra construire le
reste est à partir de là je pense que
nous avons de voir un intérêt je
remercie notre collègue sylvie robert
pour 7
proposition de loi qui est fort utile
comme cela a été dit par bien des
orateurs va apporter un socle juridique
est essentielle
je dire pour pour les bibliothèques je
suis un titre personnel présidente d'une
association qui a inventé mode un petit
peu original et atypique en ouvrant il
ya une dizaine d'années la première
bibliothèque restaurants de france et
qui fonctionne sans aucune subvention de
collectivités territoriales et qui a
permis de faire de telle sorte que nous
avons créé une forme de tiers lieux de
culture accessible à tout le monde avec
bibliothèque faisons des conférences des
concerts et une galerie d'art c'est même
une petite maison d'édition associative
la bibliothèque au de dire bibliothèque
en occitan et je crois que c'est un
élément important que d'essayer
finalement de de faire de telle sorte
qu'il puisse y avoir ce socle juridique
au travers de cette proposition de loi
et cette capacité d'innovation et
d'invention julien green disait une
bibliothèque c'est le carrefour de
toutes les humanités et je crois que ce
que nous pouvons espérer au travers de
cette proposition de loi
madame le rapporteur c'est que
finalement les bibliothèques puisse
rester encore très longtemps
ces carrefours d'humanité qui sont si
chères et si importants pour notre
avenir
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la discussion générale est close nous
passons à la discussion du texte de la
commission
je mets tout d'abord aux voix l'article
1er qui est pour contre abstentions il
est adopté l'article 2 avec une prise de
parole de jean claude tissot oui merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues tout d'abord je
tiens à saluer l'engagement et le
travail de notre collègue sénatrice
sylvie robert sur cette proposition de
loi qui vient enfin définir ça a été dit
plusieurs fois précisément les missions
des bibliothèques publiques tout en un
accompagnement quand tout en les
accompagnant vers un développement futur
ce texte unanimement salué par les
principales associations de
bibliothécaires
dès son article 2 une notion majeure en
inscrivant le principe de liberté
d'accès aux bibliothèques municipales et
intercommunales dans la loi n'oublions
pas ce rôle d'inclusion sociale qu'ont
les bibliothèques dès le plus jeune âge
dans tous les territoires ruraux comme
urbain ainsi définir la liberté d'accès
accompagné par la gratuité d'accès
l'article 3 c'est réellement permettre
une égale accessibilité à tous pour ces
lieux de culture et de savoir
l'inclusion sociale est une des missions
quotidiennes des bibliothécaires
conseiller un livre accompagné un élève
dans ses recherches aidés à écrire un
courriel ou à se connecter ainsi de
services publics mais aussi accueillir
et travailler avec les écoles participer
à des programmes auprès des publics dits
éloignés de la culture en partenariat
avec les centres sociaux les prisons les
hôpitaux
oui les bibliothèques participe
activement politiques d'inclusion
sociale et de cohésion au sein de notre
pays et au sein de notre république
mais malgré tout mais malgré
l'importance de ces équipements
culturels permettez moi juste une
remarque très actuelle nous pouvons
regretter la non prise en compte des
bibliothécaires dans les publics
prioritaires le vaccination au mois deux
derniers mois de mai dernier
voilà c'est juste un aimant peut-être
dissonant en tout cas je souhaitais le
dire ces propositions de loi bien sûr
débattu aujourd'hui dans la chambre
d'hôte est donc la bienvenue dans ce
secteur et fort de ses principes
défendus dans cette proposition de loi
je peux mais j'imagine que aujourd'hui
ça va être les catcheurs collègues vous
inviter à voter sur cet article
mais aussi l'intégralité du texte je
remercie merci chers collègues je mets
aux voix l'article 2 qui est pour contre
abstentions il est adopté
est-ce que je peux considérer que les
articles 3 4 5 6 ont le même vote
c'est à dire favorables parfait ils sont
donc adopté nous passons à l'article 7
avec un amendement numéro 2 présenté par
monsieur mambé l'île madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
voilà je dois vous avouer qu'il ya
quelques jours je n'avais pas prévu
d'intervenir dans ce débat et j'avoue
humblement que là encore que je vais pas
regarder dans le détail cette
proposition de loi est
en fait mon temps mon intervention sur
ce texte l ailier
un rendez vous que le directeur
départemental des bibliothèques de
vendée sollicité et je les rencontrais
vendredi dernier et dans le cadre de la
préservation de ce rendez-vous qui au
passage d'ailleurs était simplement
rendez-vous de courtoisie pour me dire
tout le bien qu'il pensait de la
proposition de loi de notre collègue
sylvie robert et qui l'accompagnait
qu'il l'a souhaité est comme beaucoup de
professionnels du bio tech en préparant
ce rendez-vous comme je le fais pour
tous les rendez-vous comme chacun de nos
collègues jeu j'ai lu le texte est mon
regard d'ancien maire d'anciens
présidents de communautés de communes a
été attirée par ce qui m'a semblé être
deux imprécisions ou deux compléments
apportés à ce texte est le premier
d'entre eux je verrai tout à l'heure
pour le deuxième amendement
et bien c'est une précision sur le vote
éventuel de la collectivité délibérante
jusque dans le texte il est noté dans
cet article que cela fait l'objet d'une
présentation à l'organe délibérant et un
maire pourrait être pour être questionné
en disant mais l'organe délibérant
est-ce qu'on doit voter ou pas et donc
il s'agit simplement d'un amendement de
précision qui indique que la
présentation peut être suivi d'un vote
tout simplement merci madame le
rapporteur votre avis s'il vous plaît
oui merci madame la présidente
cet amendement vise effectivement à
prévoir la possibilité d'un vote de
l'assemblée délibérante sur les
orientations générales de la politique
documentaire c'est l'article 7 je
n'avais pas voulu c'est la philosophie
de ma proposition de loi contraint d
obliger le maire à faire voter donc
cette politique documentaire
votre amendement vient préciser les
choses et être un petit peu plus
explicite en disant qu'il peut faire
voter donc c'est à la discrétion ou pas
du maire et je trouve que non seulement
ça n'enlève rien à la philosophie de cet
article mais ça le précise donc ce soir
un avis favorable
merci cher collègue madame la ministre
votre avis forum parfait je mets donc
aux voix cet amendement avec deux avis
favorables qui est pour
contre l'abstention il est adopté je
mets aux voix l'article 7 ainsi modifié
pour contre abstentions il est adopté
article 8 jeux mais aux voix qui est
pour contre abstentions il est adopté l
article 9 g un amendement le numéro 3
présenté par monsieur mandelli dame eux
la présidente madame la ministre
voilà mes chers collègues dans le même
esprit que l'amendement précédent en
fait celui ci indique que conformément à
ce que nous avons sans doute devoir tout
à l'heure et voté dans l'art dans
l'article 11 qui indique que les deux
pays s'ils devront valider et voter un
schéma de développement de la lecture
publique
il me paraissait important dans la
mesure où la compétence est aussi du
ressort des départements avec la
bibliothèque départementale que la même
règle entre guillemets soit applicable
aux départements qui devront au travers
de cet amendement s'il est adopté et
bien définir également et faire voter un
schéma de développement de la lecture
publique à l'échelon départemental
merci chers sénateurs madame le
rapporteur votre avis s'il vous plaît
oui merci madame la présidente
chers collègues donc votre amendement
propose d'inclure dans l'émission des
bibliothèques départementales
élaboration d'un schéma de développement
de la lecture publique validée par un
vote de l'assemblée départementale
je voudrais vous dire que c'est un
amendement quai pour moi une pour nous
une avancée très utile j'avais pour ne
rien vous cacher l'intention de
l'inscrire dans le cadre d'un projet de
loi que nous aurons le l'occasion
d'examiner en juillet prochain qui la
loi cadre des trois déesses parce que
nous les départements qui gère les
bibliothèques départementales vous le
savez la loi ne précise pas s'il s'agit
d'une compétence obligatoire ou
optionnel
donc nous avions avec notre collègue
colette mélot dans notre rapport
d'information pointé cette question et
nous étions pour sécuriser la compétence
lecture publique des départements je
suis heureuse de voir que vous partagez
notre objectif et j'espère vous
retrouver sur ses bancs pour défendre
donc
dans le cas de la loi cadre d un
amendement pour sécuriser cette
compétence cet amendement est une
première avancée très utile pour toutes
ces raisons je donne également un avis
favorable
merci madame la reporter madame la
ministre vous que vos robes parfait
jamais donc aux voiles cet amendement
numéro 3 avec deux avis favorables qui
est pour contre l'abstention il est
adopté je mets au voile article 9
ainsi modifié qui est pour contre
abstentions il est adopté
article 10 je le mets aux voix pour
contre abstentions article 11 même voix
j'imagine même vote
article 12 g un amendement j'ai deux
amendements
le numéro 4 présenté par madame de marco
merci madame la présidente
l'article 12 prévoit la possibilité pour
les bibliothèques territoriale de cd de
documents dont ils n'ont plus l'utilité
à des écoles fondations ou associations
caritatives à but non lucratif ces
associations ou ses fondations ne
peuvent procéder à la cession à titre
onéreux des documents mais le principe
de réalité fait que certaines
associations ne peuvent pas gérer ce
plan de redistribution à grande échelle
des documents et dans cette période de
crise sanitaire après désherbage les
bibliothèques n'ont pu procéder un
désherbage puis à une vente locale et
ont fait don des documents plutôt que de
les envoyer au pilon
cet amendement prévoit donc d'ouvrir la
possibilité de cessions à des organismes
d'accueil communautaire et d'activités
solidaires c'est à dire entre les
communautés emmaüs qui pratiquent des
prix solidaire les bénéfices de cette
cession à titre onéreux permet aux
personnes accueillies dans la communauté
de participer à des activités solidaires
et d'obtenir une forme de rémunération
cet amendement correspond à l'objectif
initial de l'article 12 qui veut limiter
la destruction de documents participe à
l'élargissement des connaissances de nos
concitoyens et favoriser des actions de
solidarité entre les différents
organismes
merci cher collègue madame le rapporteur
merci madame la présidente
ma chère collègue donc votre amendement
vise à autoriser certains bénéficiaires
de dons d'ouvragés des bibliothèques
comme emmaüs vous l'avez cité à vendre
les livres pour financer leurs activités
tout d'abord je voudrais vous rappeler
que l'article 12 de cette ppl autorise
les bibliothèques a donné les ouvrages
dont elle n'aurait plus usage à des
fondations et des associations reconnues
d'utilité publique mais c'est donc de ne
doivent pas être vendus et donc vocation
à être distribués pour mémoire en droit
je voudrais vous rappeler que les
collectivités territoriales ne peuvent
céder gratuitement leurs documents
relevant du domaine privé
les cessions à titre gratuit sont
restreintes au matériel informatique et
aux logiciels dans les mêmes conditions
que celles autorisées pour l'état et ses
établissements publics
l'article 12 de ma proposition loi et
donc une nouvelle exception à ce
principe
je comprends très bien la philosophie de
votre amendement chers collègues je
pense cependant le coc les titulaires de
droits d'auteurs et éditeurs seraient
opposés à ce développement
potentiellement important du marché du
livre d'occasion qu'il surveille avec
beaucoup d'attention et en plus il me
paraît important que cette exception
pour les livres soient bien comprises
aussi comme une modalité d'accès à la
culture pour eux un plus large public et
non pas comme une opération commerciale
quelle qu en soit et je l' ai bien
compris
l'objectif final donc j'aimerais bien
que vous retiriez votre amendement
auquel cas je vous donnerai un avis
défavorable
merci madame le rapporteur madame le
ministre votre avis excellente
argumentation madame le rapporteur avis
défavorable également madame de marco
vous retirer votre amendement je le mets
au voit très bien donc je mets aux voix
avec deux avis défavorables qui votent
pour contre abstentions il n'est pas
adopté a maintenant numéro 5 madame de
marco un amendement qui dans le même
esprit et cette fois ci pour pouvoir
céder à des entreprises de l'économie
sociale et solidaire
les livres issus des désherbages des
bibliothèques
il s'agit quand même de poser des bases
légales donc d'une pratique qui se fait
actuellement et surtout suite à la suite
au confinement ou des beaucoup de
bibliothèques ont donné donc des livres
à ce type d'association et ce type de
structures de l'économie sociale et
solidaire
voilà je connais le ressort de cet
amendement je pense que c'est la même
réponse de madame le rapporteur mais je
pense qu'il faudra un petit un moment
donc se poser la question de savoir
plutôt que de mettre au pilon des livres
dont les associations ne peuvent pas
gérer forcément où les fondations s'il
n'était pas possible d'envisager que des
structures l'économie sociale et
solidaire ou emmaüs
puisse donc récupérer ses livres de
façon à les vendre à très bas prix
puisque façon ça favorise aussi la
lecture publique de pouvoir avoir la
possibilité de d'avoir des livres un peu
cher bon merci chers collègues nous
allons avoir la réponse à votre question
grâce à madame le rapporteur chers
collègues je ne vais pas redonné les
raisons parce que sont les mêmes que
l'amendement précédent et vous l'avez
bien vous l'avait bien dit je pense que
il ya peut-être un débat à avoir sur
d'autres véhicules législatifs
vous avez posé le débat et c'est un
débat important mais dans le cas de ma
proposition de loi et parce que derrière
et la question des droits d'auteur et
des éditeurs je pense que il n'est pas
du tout opportun de faire en sorte que
lorsqu'on donne un ouvrage
et puis c'est après être revendus quels
qu'en soient les objectifs et qu'elle
conçoit les bénéficiaires donc je vous
demanderai de le retirer
auquel cas je voudrais encore un avis
défavorable madame la ministre même avis
pour les mêmes raisons à vis des oeuvres
parfait madame de marco vous retirer
vous vous maintenez vous maintenez donc
je mets aux voix avec deux avis
défavorables qui votent pour madame de
marco si vous ne votez pas pour votre
amendement ce jeu non merci
qui vote contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adoptée je mets
voile article xii notamment dès qu'ils
votent pour contre attention il est
adopté
article 13 avec l'amendement numéro 1
présentée par le gouvernement
je lève le gage prévu à l'article 13
merci infiniment madame la ministre je
le mets aux voix j'imagine qu'il va
remporter un vif succès votre avis
madame le rapporteur
je ne peux que remercier la ministre et
je donne bien évidemment un avis très
favorable
je mets donc aux voix qui votent pour
contre abstentions il est adopté merci
madame la ministre
l'article est donc supprimée par d'onde
adopté dans sa suppression pardon je
vais mettre maintenant on voit
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
y at il des demandes d'explications de
vote
madame darcos estime alain la présidente
juste un petit mot pour parce que ma
collègue elsa l achat qui a très bien
parlé tout à l'heure au nom d'autres
groupes mais remercie une fois de plus
suivi robert je veux dire que pour nous
deux c'est c'était une grande semaine
nos textes auraient dû être payées mais
finalement 1 à une nuit d'intervalle
vraiment ça a été formidable merci
encore ma la même liste d'avoir en effet
une procédure accélérée pour nos deux
textes
j'espère que en effet rapidement
l'assemblée nationale s'en saisira est
vraiment ma chers collègues je voudrais
encore te féliciter parce que voilà les
bibliothèques c'est aussi toute ta vie
et après tout ce que tu avais déjà fait
et tous les rapports qui ont été faits
au nom des bibliothèques
en effet le sénat peut être très fier de
faire porter en fait une loi
bibliothèque grâce à toi merci merci
chers collègues et le mot de la fin
revient à l'auteur de la loi madame
robert quelques mots bien sûr d'abord
pour remercier la ministre
pour remercier également le service du
livre et de la lecture parce que ils
m'ont aussi beaucoup accompagné dans la
rédaction de cette proposition de loi et
je les en remercie sincèrement je
voudrais vous remercier aussi tout ce
cher collègue remercié le président de
de la commission mais également bertrand
pelé l'administrateur et son
enthousiasme sans faille et son
attachement aux bibliothèques
je voudrais vous dire simplement une
chose c'est que pendant cette semaine
nous avons eu l'occasion
même si nous ne sommes pas si nombreux
mais finalement un petit peu de parler
culture madame la ministre
avec la proposition de loi delors est la
mienne vous avez cité des auteurs vous
avez cité des poètes
je trouve que c'est très important dans
le contexte actuel plus que jamais
peut-être non seulement de défendre la
culture mais d'évoquer ces poètes et ses
auteurs je trouve que ce sont des
moments je pourrais qualifier de grâce
en tout cas pour moi ils sont très
importants
c'est un moment aussi d'émotion parce
que j'espère mais je fais confiance à la
ministre elle a dit que votre
attachement parce que votre attachement
et les propos que vous avez cités est
évoquée dans toutes vos dans toutes vos
discussions générales ont été des propos
vraiment louangeurs à l'égal des
bibliothèques et des bibliothécaires et
pour elle parce qu'ils sont beaucoup des
femmes j'espère vraiment que cette
proposition loi se transformera en loi
ainsi que celles
de ma collègue laure darcos et nous
pourrons au sénat nous féliciter que la
première aventure de ces lois eh bien
c'était avec vous cet après midi et je
voudrais vraiment vous en remercier
merci chers collègues je mets donc aux
voix l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
relative aux bibliothèques et au
développement de la lecture publique qui
vote pour qui s'abstient qui votent
contre
je vous félicite madame l'auteur de
cette proposition de loi c'est un vote à
l'unanimité
donc nous souhaitons une longue vie à
cette proposition doit en attendant
qu'elle devienne une loi merci madame le
ministre de votre présence et de vos
encouragements
merci beaucoup
[Musique]